a giant space Arc fires its Fusion
rockets inside the ship are thousands of
human volunteers they're on a one-way
mission to colonize a distant
planet we will one day have to make this
journey it's inevitable that we go off
Planet I think we're going to have to do
it to survive as a
species the ark's first Target is is the
closest star system to the sun Alpha
centor and the journey will be
long around 40 years keeping the crew
fit and healthy is imperative but it
won't be easy a lot of things happen to
the human body when you go into
space the moment you become weightless
you instantly get kind of a full-head
feeling you get dizzy that can make you
feel
nauseous Leroy Chow spend 6 months on
the International Space Station long
enough to experience the damaging
effects of zero
gravity your bones aren't feeling any
impact so your body decides it doesn't
need bones anymore and it'll begin to
demineralize your
bones and then your muscles through
disuse of course they'll naturally
atrophy very
[Music]
quickly the human body evolved to live
with Earth's gravity without it bones
lose 2% of their mass for every month
spin in
Space the cardiovascular system suffers
too body fluids
pull heart rates and blood pressures
rise resistance training helps reduce
the
symptoms we're scheduled for 2 hours of
exercise a day on the space stations to
keep our cardiovascular system fit to
keep our muscles and our bones fit
exercise can hold off the dangerous
wasting
process but a 42-year journey to Alpha
centor without gravity would be
fatal obviously we need a permanent
solution to
weightlessness there's nothing to
prevent Us in the near future from
creating artificial
[Music]
gravity centrifugal force is the
answer
it's the force that sticks Daredevil
bikers to Vertical walls and keeps
Thrill Seekers glue to their seats in
theme
parks rotation produces this outward
force and it would be relatively simple
to create in a
spaceship by rotating a Space Capsule it
means that the astronauts inside will
experience artificial
gravity
spinning the living quarters at just the
right speed will hold off bone and
muscle
wasting but low gravity is the least of
the dangers our Pioneers will face as
they Journey deep into
space radiation is probably the biggest
challenge we're going to be exposed to
much harsher levels much higher levels
of
radiation the sun's surface shoots out a
constant stream of dangerous charged
particles protons and electrons
traveling at close to a million miles
hour these things will break your DNA
they'll cause cancer and it will kill
you the Earth's magnosphere and the
atmosphere above our heads protects us
from the worst of this radiation but far
from the earth the Pioneers will face
radiation
headon that really is the biggest
technical barrier to uh mankind sending
uh people out farther and deeper into
space it's it's not propulsion it's not
computers or navigation it's how do we
keep people
healthy beyond the boundary of our solar
system the radiation threat gets worse
charged particles come at you even
faster in some cases there are single
protons that actually pack as much of a
punch as a 100 mph fast
ball these cosmic rays are joined by an
even deadlier Force gamma rays spewed
out by violent Cosmic
events all of the cosmic phenoma from
stars
[Music]
exploding to black holes eating up large
parts of
galaxies produces radiation and
particles that are incredibly
energetic you've never seen these
particles before your body's not adapted
to them and they come at you all the
time and they're very high
energy Galactic Cosmic radiation will
rip through the cells of our human cargo
liquefying their
bodies the only hope is to somehow
Shield the
spacecraft in science fiction Starships
create a protective magnetic bubble
similar to the magnetic field that
protects the Earth
but a deflector Shield would take a huge
amount of energy to sustain and like any
electrical device it would be prone to
failure the safest option is to go low
Tech coating the ship with a thick layer
of physical
shielding shielding is not a simple
problem it's not just a matter of of
bringing a bunch of lead or anything
like that in fact what you find is that
if you do something like that uh it
absorbs the radiation and then it
re-emits it in a more dangerous
form Metals won't work but scientists
have come up with a brilliant
alternative in fact one of the best
Shields from cosmic rays is something
simple
water and it's actually something you
need to bring with you as you venture
into Interstellar space the hydrogen
atoms in water absorb high energy
particles and in sufficient volume water
can also block gamma
rays the living quarters of the Ark will
have a thick outer skin filled with the
ship's water and outside that a second
skin filled with the ship's hydrogen
supply for its Fusion
engines our astronauts are now safe from
radiation sickness and with artificial
gravity their bodies will stay strong
the deadliest threat now is their crew
mates one of the biggest challenges for
people in space are the people taking
people putting them in a tin can in an
incredibly dangerous environment having
them get along with each other for
months or years and stay alive through
the Journey is going to be an enormous
challenge we know when people go on
submarines that they have to be very
carefully tested and those submarines uh
go out for Missions that that aren't
don't certainly don't last
years we can't start a new civilization
with a crew ravaged by Cosmic boredom
infighting and mental illness it would
help if the entire crew were
unconscious one possibility which of
course again is a possibility in science
fiction is to have people be asleep
during most of
it could you put people into an induced
coma and then wake them up in time to go
do their science Mission and it might be
an easier thing to do than to say well
now you just sit still for the next 10
years the closest we come to suspended
animation in today's world is storing
human embryos in liquid
nitrogen but could we really save the
human race with test tube
babies because of the enormous hurdles
facing space travel some people have
advanced the idea well why do we have to
send humans into outer space us and
embryos or sperm and egg cells in theory
we could transport Frozen embryos across
the vast distances of space Sid stepping
the need for food or complex life
support
systems they could withstand the rigors
of space travel and weightlessness but
how would they be
socialized you put a baby in a single
place alone they don't know how to read
they wouldn't survive in fact we're very
dependent we are social
beings we would have to develop
intelligent robots to hatch the embryos
and then teach them to be
human it's conceivable that perhaps a
hundred years into the future we will
have robot nannies that can incorporate
the laws of social
interaction could a robot really raise a
child or in our rush to save Humanity
will we end up forgetting what it means
to be
human